Dave and I want to get your thoughts on
the transgender troop ban as well you
know absolutely you're right it's it's a
false choice you can do the military and
get the Goodlatte bill in right that's
the fundamental piece on immigration
which is polling higher than Obama care
for Republicans and so we failed on the
premier piece that he ran on and that
the American people want wages have been
flat for 30 years and everyone from
Bernie through president Trump wants to
fix the mess in the swamp and so he
could have just come back to town so
let's do a two-week CR and made some
major moves and the hope I would have
gotten behind him yeah it would have
been it would have been gutsy and that's
that's his that's his strength he's up
for it yeah at least we get 1.7 billion
dollars a year to maintain 770,000 empty
buildings yes square feet of empty
building office space okay so there this
is what we got that might I want to talk
briefly about this transgender troop ban
the left's gonna go crazy on this all
weekend long into the into early next
week in congressman the Commonwealth of
Virginia big military state this was
taken after some concerted study on the
issue it the the statement of the of the
White House today is among other things
the policy is set forth by the Secretary
of Defense state that transgender
persons with a history of diagnosis of
gender dysphoria individuals who the
policy state may require substantial
medical treatment including medications
and surgery are disqualified from
military service expect under except
under certain limited circumstances
according to the presidential memorandum
do you have any reason to believe that
this the timing of this is to placate
the base that's the cynic and in mania
saying oh they're throwing this out at a
Friday night because the base is up in
arms or this was planned well I mean III
think that's probably president Trump's
guts and and a lot of folks aren't happy
with playing social science with all the
major institutions in the country right
now
the primary thesis for the military's
national defense and all these were just
distracted the the the Democrats daren't
aren't so hot on policy so they do this
identity stuff throughout every major
institution we have the FBI is blowing
apart with the top ten
people being either fired or stepping
down or leaving we got so we got we got
to get back to basic business not
running trillion dollar deficits every
year as far as the eye can see I throw
that item X social engineering in the
military we don't need to do that
anymore either that we have a fighting
force we need to maintain a fighting
force and as far as as soon as they
allow transgenders to go into the
military's January 1st the policy went
into effect as of February 23rd one
person one transgendered person had
signed up for service you know god bless
the person who did that but that's the
total so far guys fantastic segment